Prof: What I'd like to
do today is to talk to you about
what it is that distinguishes
European ideas about the shared
history of the last century and
the United States.
What makes Europe European and
what makes its sense of history
different from ours.
I think the primary difference
between Europe and the United
States will be seen in about six
days,
on the 11^(th) of November,
when Armistice Day is
commemorated all over Europe.
In fact, it's now commemorated
in Eastern Europe as well as in
Western Europe,
since it took the fall of the
Soviet Union to remind people
that two million Russian
soldiers died in the First World
War,
and that the Eastern Front was
the place where the German army
won the war and where the
Russian Revolution came directly
out of it.
So, the First World War is what
made Europe in the twentieth
century European.
And the war created a series of
wounds that, to a degree,
have never healed,
to a degree.
The primary reason for that is
the bloodshed,
is the staggering casualties of
a degree and magnitude that no
one had ever seen before.
When we talk about losses on
the scale of the First World
War, we enter a surreal terrain.
I have great difficulty getting
my mind around figures of one
million casualties for the
Battle of Verdun,
in 1916,
or just about the same number
for the Battle of the Somme.
The Battle of Verdun between
February 1916 and November was
the longest battle in history.
It was ten months without a
break.
There was nothing like it in
the Second World War.
It pushed soldiers,
human beings,
beyond the limits of human
endurance.
The primary way in which this
wound has been remembered is in
terms of an array of
commemorative practices which
describe what European identity
is, not only was,
but is.
I want to suggest that there
are many reasons why the
remembrance of the First World
War is carried on throughout the
twentieth century in a defining
way.
The first is technology.
It's an accident that the First
World War happened at the very
moment that the film industry
became the centerpiece of mass
entertainment.
Hence, this was the very first
filmic war.
It was filmic in a fictional
way.
That is to say,
the technology of the day
provided motion picture cameras
for all major armies,
and indeed they were used in
all kinds of ways.
The problem was they never
filmed battle,
or almost never filmed battle.
There are one or two exceptions.
But the important point is that
generals and their staffs didn't
want cameras on the battlefield,
partly because it might produce
evidence that would be useful to
the other side.
The other part of it is that
the film might get back home.
If families got to see it,
then what would happen?
There's a famous story of the
fictional film representation of
war which is one reason why I
think it is so iconic as a
descriptive element in European
consciousness about the past.
In 1916, in the middle of the
Battle of the Somme--which was a
six-month quagmire started by
the British army on the 1st of
July 1916 and ended roughly
November 1916,
for no gain whatsoever and a
million casualties--in the
middle of it,
a part of the British
propaganda office,
it wasn't a ministry until
1918--it was all done more or
less informally until then--they
decided to make a film to buck
up public morale.
What they did was they filmed
the Battle of the Somme while it
was being fought.
But they didn't film the
fighting.
They filmed mock episodes where
soldiers in training would go
over the top in a totally
fictional representation of war.
The problem was that the people
who saw this didn't know that it
was phony.
When the film was shown in the
middle of 1916,
in August-September 1916--the
battle started on the 1^(st) of
July--it was shown all over
Britain.
Twenty million people saw it.
That is half of the population
of the country.
There has never been a film
that was seen by half of the
population of any country in the
world before that date or since.
It broke all box office records.
What it showed in silence was
the preparation for the battle,
the huge artillery barrage,
and then men going over the
top.
Because of this phony--there
were men who went over the top,
stopped for a moment and then
slid right down again,
which caused women in the
theaters that saw that to faint.
They didn't know that this was
simply nonsense,
that it was fiction.
I think the critical point to
bear in mind,
therefore, is that as a filmic
war, the war turned into myth at
the very moment that it was
being fought.
Nobody had ever seen the
landscape of the dark side of
the moon that was created by
industrialized war between 1914
and 1918.
The way it was represented by
film was completely fictional.
Film comes straight out of
theater.
It has a proscenium arch and it
has a vanishing point.
Anyone who's ever been anywhere
near a battle will realize that
battles don't have vanishing
points.
People vanish in them,
but they go in every
conceivable direction.
The representation of war
became a matter of myth right in
the middle of the war itself.
It became a battle of myth to
be remembered.
I'll give you another example
which makes the point really
powerful, very,
very powerful.
In February 1916 the German
army decided to push through
French lines at Verdun.
This big ten-month battle,
which is the biggest of all
time, took place.
In the course of it a series of
completely made-up stories
turned into legend.
One is called the Trench of the
Bayonets.
What it shows is there were no
trenches in the Battle of
Verdun.
There were isolated pockets of
men in big underground forts.
There was simply artillery
barrage going on day and night
for ten months.
Little pockets of men would be
caught in one part of the
battle, and they stayed put to
make sure that the Germans would
not get through.
The French line was in ils
ne passeront pas.
They won't get through and they
didn't.
One group of such men were
almost certainly buried by a
landslide.
The weight of artillery barrage
in the mud would mean the earth
would move when,
indeed,
the artillery barrage hit a
particularly wet part of the
front.
So, a group of men were buried
alive, which is a very normal
practice in the course of the
First World War.
The German group of soldiers,
the platoon that took it,
put bayonets basically sticking
up out of the ground to indicate
to the Frenchmen where to find
the dead,
so that they could be buried
during a lull in the fighting.
The French didn't interpret it
that way.
What they said was,
"Here are fifteen French
men who stood with their
bayonets there until they were
buried alive and they didn't
move an inch in the passeront
pas."
This is a completely made up
story.
But it became a sacred site
commemorated every 22^(nd) of
February 1917,1918,
1919.
In other words,
the war itself created a mythic
set of representations of war
that have come up to the
present.
The Great War created myth in
other ways.
Another one came from the
landing in Gallipoli.
Gallipoli was a Turkish
peninsula south of Istanbul,
Constantinople then.
It's about a four-hour taxi
drive in lousy traffic.
It probably took longer then.
The idea of the Allies was to
knock Turkey out of the war,
help Russia and possibly
encircle Germany by not
attacking directly through the
western front,
but coming around through Asia
Minor.
This landing was a catastrophic
failure.
It was the brainchild of
Winston Churchill who,
until 1940 when Hitler made him
the great man that we all
remember, was a complete
failure.
politically and in military
affairs.
Gallipoli was his idea,
and he shared in the form of
what is now called Orientalism,
a complete underestimation of
the capacity of Muslim
populations,
Asian populations,
brown people,
to fight against Europeans.
So, nobody had a look at the
ground where the Allies were
supposed to land at Gallipoli.
They didn't actually take
account of the fact that there
were very big cliffs to climb.
When they got there,
they just reproduced trench
warfare that had already
existed.
It was a complete failure.
The landing, though,
took place on the night of the
25^(th) of April 1915,
and the people used for it were
Australian and New Zealand
troops,
alongside British and French
ones.
That landing was the birth of
the Australian nation.
To this day,
Anzac Day--Australia,
New Zealand Expeditionary
Corps--Anzac Day is sacred.
It's the 4^(th) of July in
Australia.
It's the moment of celebration,
through the shedding of blood,
the winning of national pride.
The point I'm trying to make
initially is that remembering
the First World War is
remembering sacred themes that
define nations.
The oddity of the First World
War is that these nations were
defined first of all because
they're a part of imperial
powers,
but this war was at the one and
the same time the apogee and the
beginning and the end of empire.
Hence, nations that affirm
their loyalty to Britain by
dying on the beaches of
Gallipoli,
or in the hills of Gallipoli,
earned the right to break away
from Britain.
This sacred moment is how the
Great War turned into myth.
If you think this is light,
you're mistaken.
This is big-time politics to
this day.
Yesterday, in the Sydney
Morning Herald,
two Australian politicians
virtually came to blows about
how to remember Gallipoli,
because it is at the core of
the notion or of the idea of
what the nation has to be.
The first point I want to make
is remembering the First World
War is remembering a series of
myths.
They're iconic in the sense
that they describe not just what
happened at a particular moment,
but they describe what the rest
of the twentieth century might
become and did become.
And that is the second point I
think I'd like to draw to your
attention.
What makes remembering the
First World War so important is
that it became the way in which
war was configured throughout
the twentieth century in Europe.
In many respects,
this is a defining difference
between the United States and
Europe.
The Second World War in this
country is quite different from
the First.
The United States didn't really
suffer the injuries of any major
European country in the First
World War.
One hundred thousand American
soldiers died in the First World
War.
Perhaps 40,000 of them,
and there's a dispute on this,
but perhaps 40,000 of them died
from the Spanish Flu,
the worst influenza epidemic in
history.
It hit everybody.
It hit civilians.
It hit soldiers.
But it particularly preyed,
as many mutant viruses do,
on young adults.
So, it got soldiers.
Well, 100,000 dead was roughly,
just roughly,
what the British army suffered
in three weeks on the Battle of
the Somme, in one battle.
The scale of casualties in the
First World War is what makes it
everybody's business.
The second reason why
remembering the First World War
is iconic is that it is
universal in Europe.
It's family history.
Let me give you an example of
what that means.
If you ever visit the
extraordinary power of
individual graveyards at the
scene of the landings at
Normandy,
you will find that there are
graves of 3,000 American
soldiers who died in the course
of the first day of the landing
on the 6^(th) of June 1944.
That landing on the 6^(th) of
June 1944 was terrible.
It was an extraordinary day.
It was a day that should be
remembered and is remembered.
If any of you see the Steven
Spielberg film Saving Private
Ryan, you'll see it.
It is iconic.
It should be.
The first day of the Battle of
the Somme, on the 1^(st) of July
1916, was 20,000 British men
killed.
The first day of the landing at
Normandy, 3,000 Americans
killed.
The landing at Normandy,
compared to the Battle of the
Somme,
shows us that the iconic battle
for Britain of the First World
War was six times as murderous
in one day as the landings at
Normandy.
That sheer scale of casualties
means that remembering the Great
War means remembering loss of
life that became universal
throughout families,
throughout Europe.
This is extraordinary in many
respects.
Until 1914, war was not
democratic.
Military service was not
Either it was aristocratic and
rural, in terms of the officer
corps, that's why the cavalry
mattered so much.
They came from the land.
Or it was more or less the men
whom the general who defeated
Napoleon, Wellington,
put it,
who were "the scum of the
earth."
Either the unemployable
overpopulation of major cities,
or indeed the unemployable
populations of rural life in
Europe, as well.
Now, what happens in 1914 is
conscription,
universal conscription
antedating the war presented
armies of a size that had never
before been pulled together.
These armies suffered
casualties of roughly one out of
eight killed and one out of
three wounded.
We're talking about seventy
million men in uniform in the
First World War,
nine million men killed,
roughly twenty-five million men
wounded.
One out of every two men who
served in the First World War
was a casualty.
There were eight million
prisoners of war.
In those camps illness was
likely to kill you more than
anything else.
The critical thing to bear in
mind, therefore,
is that the First World War
created an astonishing and
unprecedented challenge of
commemoration.
The first challenge was the
missing.
I want to take you through the
commemorative forms that the
First World War created,
which created cultural
practices that are still very
important today.
Anybody going to England
today--and I mean today,
I was there last weekend in
Oxford--will see everybody
wearing a little red poppy in
your lapel.
This is what you buy for a
couple of pennies,
whatever you want to give as a
contribution to a charity called
The Royal British Legion,
the biggest charity in Britain.
It is still to this day the
biggest charity for those
families,
and indeed survivors,
and successive generations of
those who served their country
and who were wounded or died in
it.
The critical thing to bear in
mind about this is that the
mythic representation of war,
which came out of film,
has been matched by what I
would call a family
representation of war that comes
through cultural practices of
remembrance.
We should never ever get away
from the fact that remembering
is a business.
People make money out of it.
That's why films sell so well.
The History Channel is
dominated by stories about war.
It's an important thing to bear
in mind that people make money
out of representing war.
It's an important thing to keep
in mind.
But that's too cynical to
suffice for a discussion of how
the First World War was
remembered.
It was remembered and still is
remembered within families.
The answer to "Why is
that?"
It's because of the
universalization of bereavement.
What's the problem?
The problems are threefold.
The first is the missing.
The second is,
in some sense,
the irrelevance of conventional
religious practices.
The third is the search for
some kind of collective
statement of why these men died.
For what?
What price, victory?
The missing.
Half of those men who died in
the First World War,
and we're talking about nine
million men, have no known
graves.
Not a trace of them exists.
This, by the way,
is exactly the same proportion
of those who were killed at
Ground Zero on 9-11.
Half of them have vanished
completely.
There are traces that matter a
great deal to the families of
the survivors,
the survivors who need
something to remember,
to mourn.
The fact that roughly four
million men died without a trace
made commemorating war very,
very difficult.
Conventional religious
practices require a site,
a grave,
a place to go to where
individuals can honor those who
die and take their lives up once
again,
let the loss go.
What possible ways do they have
to handle this?
During the war, nothing.
Because the confusion over
casualties of war,
which always happens in
wartime, was overwhelming.
If a family got a message
saying,
"Your husband,"
"Your brother,"
"Your son,"
"Your fiancé
is missing in action,"
it could mean anything.
It could mean that the
individual was in a prison camp
on the other side of the line.
It could mean that the
individual was in a hospital.
It could mean that there was a
confusion of identity and that
the person was still alive,
but somebody else found his dog
tag.
It could mean that the person
had been blown to pieces and
there was nothing that remained
of him.
None of that could be sorted
until the end of the war,
and even then it couldn't be
sorted out.
The loss of knowledge,
the lack of knowledge about the
most fundamental question of war
is the most poignant origin of a
series of commemorative
practices that followed it.
Given the scale of the losses,
the conventional churches were
not able to handle the problem
of helping the bereaved or those
who were, as it were,
in no man's land,
in Purgatory.
In fact, Purgatory is an
interesting idea.
If you think about it,
it's centered to a certain kind
of popular Catholicism in the
nineteenth century.
Purgatory means that people who
are on the way to heaven have to
wait a while,
and maybe,
maybe just the good works that
you and I might do will help
them get there sooner,
rather than later.
It's a medieval idea.
The Catholic Church had to
jettison the idea of Purgatory,
which died in the First World
War,
because no one wanted to put up
with the idea that an individual
who died for his country had to
wait for 100 years in Purgatory
in order to be able to get to
heaven.
Religious practices had to
change to handle the
unprecedented losses of war.
Those who went to the churches
for solace found very little,
because there was very little
the churchmen could do,
could say.
Why did I lose three sons?
What did they die for?
The phrases,
the noble phrases of patriotism
last only so long,
and most of the time don't get
you through the night.
Well, what did individuals do?
The first thing they did was to
move to the pagan perimeters of
Christianity.
John Merriman referred you to a
wonderful film by Abel Gance
about the return of the dead
called J'Accuse,
I Accuse,
which is accusing war,
accusing the sun of not
stopping war.
It's accusing everybody of this
insanity that had no end to it.
Well, the pagan perimeters of
Christianity are the areas where
the occult lives.
It's the areas where people
believe, faute de mieux,
because they have no choice in
extra sensory perception.
This is a period not just of
the film industry,
but the emergence of radio.
It's a world where telegraphy
was a quite normal means of
communication,
with underground cables,
Reuters dispatched stories all
over the world.
For millions of families the
idea of getting in touch with
the missing or the dead seemed
quite appealing.
These are not fools.
These are not people who are,
as it were, bought by the Elmer
Gantrys of this world.
These are ordinary people or
very intelligent people who are
prepared to suspend disbelief
about extrasensory perception in
order to be able to find some
solace,
some way of understanding the
world in which they live.
There was an extraordinary
efflorescence,
development of spiritualism,
of séances.
One of the great carriers of
this message was Arthur Conan
Doyle, who was the author of the
great, the ultimate rationalist,
Sherlock Holmes.
When his son died and was
missing, completely missing,
he became one of the great
figures in the development of
the spiritualist movement.
Churches have no part in that
because speaking to the dead has
no mediation.
Christianity couldn't be
interested in this.
Jewish religion has no time for
it.
Islam has no time for it
whatsoever.
But it just shows you that the
scale of the catastrophe of the
human loss of the First World
War challenged conventional
institutions and frameworks for
understanding what was
happening.
If séances are a kind of
collective remembrance,
they created,
as it were,
the precedent for the ones that
have left their most powerful
marks,
not only on Europe but beyond
it, as well.
These are war memorials.
The need to create a substitute
tomb, a substitute place in
front of which to mourn,
is what creates the
extraordinary vogue of war
memorials.
You don't have to go very far
to see them.
All you have to do is go
through Commons,
and you'll see two war
memorials that were created at
the same moment,
right after the First World
War.
When you see the names of Civil
War vets who were Yale men,
when you go through Commons on
the walls,
you should recognize that was
completed in the 1920s,
at the same time as there is a
façade,
a war memorial in front of
Commons with the names of the
battles that American soldiers
fought in.
In front of that is a cenotaph.
The cenotaph,
an empty tomb,
says that these men died for
liberty, and so on.
It is an empty tomb.
This is the critical point to
bear in mind.
The enormous development of
commemorative forms,
in particular sculptured,
architectural war memorials in
the twentieth century,
comes from the First World War.
Anyone who goes--and I think
it's marvelous that we can talk
about this in this particular
room.
Anyone who goes to see Maya
Linn's Vietnam Veterans Memorial
will see an outcome of a lecture
on First World War commemoration
that took place in this room,
where Maya Linn was a student.
She studied First World War
memorials in order to create the
Vietnam Veterans Memorial.
Why?
If you go to the Vietnam
Veterans Memorial you'll
understand the genius of First
World War commemoration.
The only thing that matters are
the names.
The names are what matters.
The highly-polished granite
surface of the Vietnam Veterans
Memorial has your own reflection
forced back upon you,
to touch the names is the way
to find a means,
inadequate perhaps,
symbolic perhaps,
to bring the dead back home,
to bring them to the center of
American history in the middle
of the Mall at the intersection
between the Lincoln Memorial and
the Washington memorial.
It is an extraordinary
gathering together of the bones,
of the remains of the dead who
were buried in Europe or never
found.
Why does this matter?
It matters because the
universalization of mourning,
of bereavement in the First
World War meant that these war
memorials are all over Europe.
They're everywhere.
There are 38,000 of them in
England.
Every village has one.
Every commune,
I think, bar twelve in all of
France.
There are 30,000 of them in
France alone.
These war memorials are
extraordinary in many respects.
I want to tell you about them
today.
They are places where,
next Tuesday,
on the 11^(th) of November,
there will be ceremonies.
It's a public holiday in France.
The mayor of the town will be
at the head of a
procession--this is
choreographed all over the
country--in which there will be
100 school children who will
march in the rain and the sleet,
it doesn't matter,
to the local war memorial.
What happens then is that the
mayor reads out the names of
those from a small village or
from a town who died in the
First World War.
The children in the school
after the name of Cohen Albert
will say "pr&eacu
te;sent," will answer
for the men who aren't there.
This bonding between the living
and the dead,
the bringing back of the dead
to their own villages,
to their homes,
was a substitute burial
ceremony for the ones that could
never take place.
How did it all happen?
The first point that has to be
made is that the commemorative
wave took place through
political leadership.
Politics means many things.
The first thing it has to mean
is that there is a fundamental
difference between the way in
which men are remembered in the
winners and in the losers.
In the case of Germany,
where there were two million
soldiers who died in the First
World War, this is an enormously
difficult problem.
The reason is that you not only
need to remember the dead,
but you have to find a way and
a form to answer an eternal
question.
The question is:
how is it possible to glorify
those who die in war without
glorifying war itself?
The extraordinary wave of
commemorative activity,
the cultural practices of
commemoration that were
universal in Europe in the 1920s
and 1930s have many different
answers to it.
Most of the time what happens
is that politics became local,
that small groups of people in
small towns and villages took it
upon themselves to answer the
question: What will we do?
How will we remember the men of
our village?
Given the numbers,
we're talking about three,
four brothers in agrarian
towns.
We're talking about fathers and
sons who never came back.
We're talking about the
absolutely personal,
face-to-face culture of village
life.
Everyone knew the names.
Everybody knew the families.
What this means is that it may
be the case that high politics
set out certain lines--the
cabinets, the politicians,
the generals.
But what's extraordinary about
Europe between the wars is how
democratic commemoration was,
and how much life there was in
civil society in order to create
forms that were separate.
That's why I mentioned the
poppy fund.
This is a private organization.
It's not a public charity.
It's not the state.
It's civil society speaking its
compassionate language of
remembering not only the fallen,
but those left behind,
the widows, the orphans,
and so on.
I'll give you an example of how
civil society and state power
differ and vary.
On the 14^(th) of July 1919,
just two weeks after the
signing of the peace treaty on
the 28^(th) of June 1919,
when the Germans were forced to
accept the terms of the Treaty
of Versailles,
there was a victory parade in
Paris.
That victory parade had a march
past the Champs-Elysées,
through the Arc de Triomphe.
It's only happened twice in
history and this was one of
them, to celebrate the victory.
The French were there.
The Americans were there.
The Brits were there.
The Italians were there.
All the Allies were there.
There are two things that
happened.
One was that Georges
Clemenceau,
the French prime minister,
decided in this spectacle,
"We need a symbol of the
lost generation."
So, he had a
papier-mâché
catafalque built,
a very big ornate plinth.
On top of it was a cenotaph,
an empty tomb,
to symbolize the tombs of all
those soldiers who died in the
war, half of whom have no known
graves.
To start the victory parade,
Clemenceau insisted that the
people who lead the way are the
most badly mutilated men of the
war,
the
gueules-cassés,
men with broken faces,
the men without arms,
the men without legs.
The use of this vanguard of the
suffering transformed a victory
parade into a day of mourning.
This was extraordinary.
It was absolutely extraordinary.
The Brits decided if there's
going to be something on the
14^(th) of July,
we'd better do something,
too.
It'll take five days for us to
get everybody back over.
On the 19^(th) of July we need
a victory parade,
too.
Three-quarters of a million
British men died in the war,
another 250,000 from the empire
and so on, dominions.
A million men from the British
forces died in the First World
War.
We need a victory parade.
So, they asked the architect,
Edwin Lutyens,
to put together another
papier-mâché
memorial called The Cenotaph,
an empty tomb.
They put it right in the middle
of Whitehall,
official London,
right next to 10 Downing
Street,
next to Buckingham Palace,
basically a small stroll down
to the houses of parliament,
right in the middle of official
London.
They had their parade.
But that wasn't the end of it.
Two million people came to it,
and they all deposited whatever
they had to offer to the dead of
the Great War,
because this was an empty tomb.
It wasn't the empty tomb of
Christ.
It was a Greek form.
This drove the churchmen
leading the Church of England
apoplectic.
It meant that the language of
commemoration was ecumenical and
not Christian.
Why should that be?
Lutyens was the man who
designed New Delhi.
He was the architect of empire.
He wanted a memorial that would
suffice for Hindu soldiers who
had died,
Muslim soldiers,
Jewish soldiers,
Anglican, Catholic,
Irish, whatever,
people of no belief at all,
and he found it.
He found the simplest possible
way.
As a result of this
extraordinary outpouring of
feeling, literally flowers they
kept on having to shovel away
because there were so many
things left.
Understandably.
These are families who finally
found a way to express perhaps a
form of symbolic exchange.
It happens in the Vietnam Wall,
too.
People leave things.
Why?
These people whose names are on
the wall, those people who died,
represented by the cenotaph
have given everything.
I need to give something.
Pilgrimage is hard.
It's not tourism.
It should be difficult.
You should give, not just get.
The critical thing there is
that clearly the British people
voted with their feet for the
national war memorial.
So, the cabinet said,
"Lutyens,
could you do it again,
this time in stone?"
He did.
He did it again in stone.
A year later when the Unknown
Soldier was buried in
Westminster Abbey,
where did people go?
They went and paid their
respects.
You can still do it today.
The Abbey is the home of kings
and poets.
No, the people's monument is
The Cenotaph in Whitehall,
not the church of the kings,
but it's the sacred space of
the people.
It remains so to this day.
Now, that man,
Edwin Lutyens,
designed another set of war
memorials that lead us directly
to Maya Linn.
Thiepval, T-H-I-E-P-V-A-L is a
small village that no longer
exists in the Somme,
in northern France.
There he was asked,
eighteen years later,
to do a memorial for the 73,000
British soldiers who died in
that one battle,
and have no known graves.
What he created was an
extraordinary arc,
an Arc of Triumph that
basically has small arches on
top of it and then nothing.
He reduced the Arc of Triumph
to nothingness.
The only thing you do is when
you walk up to it,
my eyesight is dreadful,
but younger people do it too.
It just depends.
When you get close--for me it's
very close,
for other people it's further
away--you all of a sudden see
that the walls of this arch that
he built in Thiepval are
completely covered with names.
There's a vanishing point where
you suddenly see them.
From a distance you can't see
it.
It just looks like a
façade.
There are the names.
It's that which Maya Linn heard
about in this lecture hall,
when Vincent Scully talked
about Lutyens and commemoration,
that inspired her to create the
Vietnam Veterans Memorial.
She's told me what it felt like
to sit in this room and do it.
She actually submitted her
design for that memorial as the
design that was ultimately the
winning design in the
competition.
It was anonymous.
By the way, she got a B for it
in her class.
I'll leave that aside.
"'Judgment is mine,'
sayeth the Lord."
All I can do is to tell you
that the forms that were created
in the cenotaph were ones that
have endured throughout the
twentieth century to describe
how war is remembered.
Now, The Cenotaph,
as I say, is pre-Christian.
It's one more move away from
the institutionalization of
religion.
It's not that the sacred died
in twentieth-century Europe;
it moved out of the churches.
It can be found elsewhere.
One of the places where it will
be found next Tuesday is in
front of war memorials that were
placed all over villages,
towns, marketplaces,
all over Europe.
Let me return to that process.
The first I said is political.
Small groups of people,
the busybodies,
the committeemen that always
exist in small towns with
nothing better to do,
retired men or men of leisure,
sometimes women.
What they did was,
"We want to design this
ourselves."
The first thing you have to
figure out is:
How much does it cost?
Hence, we should always
recognize that commemoration is
a business.
The cost factor actually
matters substantially.
The reason why it matters
substantially is that if you
want something sculptural,
if you want something like a
piece of architecture,
the cheapest possible form of
stone is an obelisk.
You don't have to do much.
You just hack it here or there
and that's it.
It has a great advantage,
which is that it's Egyptian;
it's pre-Christian again.
It doesn't require you to
distinguish between Protestant,
Catholic, Jews,
or anybody else.
It's an ecumenical form and
it's the most popular one.
The second problem is that in
France,
in particular--Germany has its
own headaches--but in France,
in particular,
church and state had been
separated in 1905,
and rather violently separated.
No crosses, except in some
Catholic areas where they said,
"I don't really care.
We're going to have a cross no
matter what,"
which is true in Catholic
Brittany, in the northwest of
the country.
Most of the time there are not
crosses.
What they show primarily are
two kinds of representations.
The first is of a Gallic
rooster, which again could be
bought through a mail order
catalog, or a soldier,
the poilu.
The British liked to see their
soldiers shaved.
For the French,
the idea of a soldier should be
somebody who's a hairy one,
a poilu,
somebody who never shaved.
Having a beard is being
masculine, being a tough guy,
being a soldier who won the
war.
A poilu could be bought,
again, on a mail order catalog.
Overwhelmingly,
and this is a very important
point, overwhelmingly,
the images are not triumphal.
They are mournful.
Again, these were decided by
small groups of people who put
together money in order to
describe the ways in which war
memorials should be organized,
should be designed,
and, indeed,
should be paid for.
They were paid for by popular
subscription overwhelmingly,
pennies, sous,
francs, deutschmarks,
whatever, whatever you had.
That's the way it was done.
What about the inscriptions?
Once more I want to reinforce
the point that I made earlier
about the democratic nature of
loss.
Ninety-five percent of war
memorials list people either
alphabetically or by the year or
the time in which they died,
the sequence of their death.
Only five percent of all war
memorials in Europe that I've
ever seen,
and I've tried to collect
material all over the place on
this,
have men listed by rank.
There is a democracy of death
and of commemoration in highly
inegalitarian societies.
It is something extraordinary
that goes on when loss is so
general it becomes apparent that
it isn't possible to separate
those who died in uniform,
in high rank,
from those who died as private
soldiers.
One important point to bear in
mind is that once the choice of
place was made,
and the choice of form was
made,
and the money was gathered
together and paid to the artist
or the sculptor who would do
this,
then we come to the third part
of the commemorative process.
The first is political.
By that I mean small politics
more than big politics.
The second is business,
the money, the commissioning,
the putting together of the
project.
The third is the ritual.
What do people do when they
stand in front of a war
memorial?
The answer is very different
things.
The first thing that happens in
the front of war memorials,
and it still happens,
is that women enter the
narrative of war.
Women are at the center of the
commemorative practice.
They are not at the center of
the narratives of war from the
battlefield or,
indeed, from the military
perspective itself.
There are those who believe
that, indeed,
the gendering of the narratives
of war separates the stories
told by soldiers in novels and
memoirs from those of the
societies for which they fought
and for which they died.
I'm not sure if that is true or
not.
But what we can say,
and there are thousands of
photographs that show it,
is that the ritual that happens
in front of memorials are
rituals of families.
In conventional terms,
by that I mean historically
overdetermined ways,
women have been associated with
mourning practices since the
Egyptians.
There are tombs in the Valley
of the Queens in Luxor that show
professional mourners,
women who have tears painted on
their cheeks,
from the time of the pharaohs.
Whether that is true or not,
the notion of Mater Dolorosa,
Stabat Mater,
"His mother was
there," is a Catholic trope
of great power and importance in
understanding how societies
configure loss of life in war.
So, the first point is that
women and children,
families are there.
The second is there is a
didactic function.
School children come there.
This, I think,
is a very important point to
bear in mind.
Overwhelmingly,
and this is true in Germany
until the 1930s,
Italy it's true until the late
1920s,
and it's true all over Britain
and France,
and certainly in the dominions.
The rituals have a by-word that
dominates the message.
It is "never again,"
the phrase we frequently
associate with the Holocaust,
with the war against genocide.
Yes, that's true,
but the phrase "never
again" comes out of the
First World War.
It's what dominates the
commemorative practices of the
inter-war period.
This is the war to end all wars.
This is the war that makes war
impossible.
This is a war so dreadful that
it is not at all the purpose of
those who go to commemorative
forms to prepare the next
generation for their turn.
On the contrary.
The notion of commemoration in
inter-war Europe is "never
again."
That explains why the
commemorative power of the
period around the First World
War is not repeated after the
Second.
In France you can see this
anywhere.
In Britain it's there, too.
In Germany there are more
difficult reasons,
obviously, to handle this.
In Eastern Europe,
where the massacres were so
gigantic, it's almost
impossible.
What happens in Western Europe
is that the names of those who
die in the Second World War are
tacked on to First World War
memorials.
Part of the reason is financial.
If the First World War
impoverished Europe,
the Second World War bankrupted
it.
Without the Marshall Plan,
who knows?
The important point is that
there's another reason.
How many times can you say,
"never again"?
If the idea was that these men
died to make war impossible,
in other words,
their sacrifices were such as
to eliminate the need for their
children to go to war again,
then what do you do in 1939?
This is true in Germany, too,
where the 1^(st) of September,
1939,
the outbreak of the Second
World War was not greeted by
marching bands,
and parades,
and so on.
It was a day of sadness in
Germany as it was elsewhere,
because everybody knew,
and they knew the costs;
the Great War had told them
what war is.
The conclusion I want to draw
on is this.
Remembering the First World War
has taken many different forms.
I've dealt with the filmic
mystification of it.
There's a big business in
novels, in memoirs,
in an area of what we might
call factoids that are half
fictional and half true.
Robert Graves' Goodbye to
All That is still in print
eighty years after he wrote it.
There are many such novels,
All Quiet on the Western
Front, that are enormous
bestsellers.
We should accept the fact that
the media matters.
I think the critical point to
bear in mind is that the
casualties of the First World
War were so devastating that
even the losses of the Second
World War didn't change the
landscape of remembrance that
was constructed between 1918 and
1939.
War means something in Europe
that it doesn't mean in this
country.
The reasons can be found in all
of these commemorative
practices.
It is clear to me that
political culture follows
history, follows the
understandings people develop of
the world in which they live.
Europeans see war differently
from Americans.
It doesn't stop there from
being militaristic groups,
and those like the Nazis who
wanted to "get it right
this time around,"
and reverse the verdict of 1918
under the Treaty of Versailles.
But there's no doubt in my mind
that the First World War message
of "never again"
survived the Nazis,
survived Stalin,
to create a different kind of
Europe in which armies don't
matter anymore.
They're there.
But in the question of a great
historian,
James Sheehan from Stanford,
who just wrote a history of
twentieth century,
and the question that he put in
his title, we have,
I think,
the final legacy of the
commemoration of the First World
War.
His book is entitled Where
Have All the Soldiers Gone?
In late-twentieth-century
Europe, states are defined in
terms of the way in which they
defend the wellbeing of their
populations.
No longer are states defined in
terms of the military force that
they can deploy in defense of
their national interests or
their imperial power.
The First World War put,
as it were,
the beginnings--hammered in the
nails in the coffin of the old
vision that the state is that
institution which has the
monopoly on the legitimate use
of physical force.
The story of warfare killed the
old idea of state sovereignty.
It wasn't dead before the Nazis
made it necessary for us to
develop something different.
But it is the remembrance of
the First World War which left
traces in families,
which are the most powerful
reasons why the First World War
has become and remains the
iconic disaster that has created
a Europe that no one had ever
seen before,
and that was vastly different,
in the minds of ordinary
people,
than the Europe that existed in
1914.
Thank you very much.
>